CLIVE MOLER: The
Lotka-Volterra Altera predator
prey equations are the
granddaddy of all models
involvement competition
between species.
They are the
foundation of fields
like mathematical ecology.
Think of the two species
as rabbits and foxes
or moose and wolves or
little fish in big fish.
Y1 represents the prey,
who would live peacefully
by themselves if there
were no predators.
I've chosen the units
of time and population
so that the
coefficients in front
of the leading
linear terms are one.
So y1 prime equals y1
represents exponential growth
of the prey in the
absence of any predators.
The predators need the
prey, live on the prey.
So in the absence of any
prey, this minus sign
is all important.
So y2 prime equals minus y2
represents exponential decay.
And the predators
die off exponentially
in the absence of any prey.
But then here are
the non-linear terms.
These are like logistics terms,
except with the interaction
between the two species.
The growth of Y1 is limited
by the presence of y2.
So y1 will grow until this term
becomes 0 one y2 read reaches
mu2.
On the other hand,
the decay of y2
becomes 0 when y1 reaches mu1.
To complete this specification,
we need the initial conditions.
So we have two values
eta 1 and eta 2,
which are the initial
values of y1 and y2.
So these four parameters,
two mus and two etas,
are the four parameters we have
in our predator prey model.
Don't worry about the fact that
these are continuous variables
and that we can have non-integer
numbers of individuals.
We can have half of a rabbit
or a tenth of a moose.
These are, after
all, models that
are idealized versions of
what's happening in nature.
The critical points are when
the derivatives become 0.
There's a critical
point at the origin.
But the interesting one is
when these terms become 0.
So that's the point
where y1 and y2
are equal to the mu1 and mu2.
We have to look at the Jacobian.
And here's the
Jacobian in general.
And at the critical point, the
Jacobian-- here's the Jacobian.
The eigenvalues of the
Jacobian are plus or minus I.
And so this critical
point is a stable center
with a period 2pi.
So these are
non-linear equations.
We can't express the
solution in terms
of simple analytic functions.
We have to compute
them numerically.
But we do know this
about their behavior.
If the initial conditions are
close to the critical point,
the solution is periodic.
The period is close to 2pi.
And the orbit is
close to an ellipse.
On the other hand, if the
initial conditions are far
from the critical
point, then it turns out
the solution is still periodic.
But the period is greater
than 2pi and the orbit
is far from an ellipse.
OK, let's bring up MATLAB
and compute a solution.
We need the parameters.
Here's a mu and an eta.
And I'll set the
differential equation.
And then choose ODE 45 and
we'll integrate from 0 to 25.
And here's the solution.
It's periodic.
A predator and a prey.
And it looks like
the period, it's
returning back to the initial
condition is 100 and 400.
And it's returning back
to that along about here.
And we've integrated
over something
more than three periods.
I happen to know that
the period is 6.5.
And so I can-- I'm
going to set-- I want
to compute to higher accuracy.
10 to the minus 6.
And let's capture the
solution and integrate
over three periods.
It generated 337 points.
Let's plot it with
the finer dots.
And we can see here, we've
gone over three periods
and return back to our
initial values of 100 and 300.
And now I'm going
to use something
that'll show off the
periodicity of function
in MATLAB called Comet.
One orbit.
Two orbits.
Three orbits.
Determining the period
of a periodic solution
is often the important
part of a calculation.
In the MATLAB ODE suite, this
is done with an event handler.
So I'm going to use ODE's set to
provide an event handler called
Pit Stop.
And here's the code in Pit Stop.
This code is called every
time step in the integration.
And I'm not going to
go into detail here,
but it computes a
function g that we're
looking to see when this is 0.
And when g returns to 0,
the integration is stopped.
I'm going to-- I have a
display function in here.
Ordinarily, this
wouldn't be here.
But I want to look
at this to see
how the calculation is done.
It says, terminate when
y returns to the point
where its angle mu is the
same as the angle between eta
and mu.
This is more reliable
than just finding
when the solution returns
back to its initial condition.
So let's run ODE 45 and
tell it to integrate over
an infinite time step,
over an infinite interval.
That's not going to
happen, because we're
going to stop as soon as g is 0
but with the option vector set
with this event handler.
So here it is.
And here's the output
produced by Pit Stop
as we integrate along.
Here's the values
that it's found.
And here's where g returns to 0.
I've produced a t vector
with 117 values in it.
And the final value
of t is this value
that I said was the
period of this solution.
So that's how the
period was determined
by this event handling
feature in the ODE solvers.
Great.
I have a program called
Predator Prey that's
in the collection of programs
that comes with NCM, Numerical
Computing with MATLAB.
My book that's available
on the MathWorks website.
Predator prey offers this
graphic user interface
to demonstrate what we've been
talking about the predator prey
equations.
The top display shows the
phase plane plot, the plot
of prey versus predator.
And the bottom display shows
the time series plot, the plot
of the two populations.
And initially, it's
set at the conditions
we've been talking about.
Here's 400 rabbits and 100
foxes around the critical point
of 300 rabbits and 200 foxes.
And here's the period
of 6.5 some odd
that we've been working with.
Now, it says drag either dot.
And you can change
the initial conditions
or the critical point.
If I bring the initial
conditions close
to the critical point,
then the phase plane plot
becomes close to ellipse.
And the period
becomes close to 2pi.
This is 6.28, which
is twice 3.14.
But if I change it so
that the two are far away
from each other, then
the phase plane plot
becomes quite different
from an ellipse.
It's always periodic.
That's an amazing thing about
these nonlinear equations.
They always have a
periodic solution.
But now as you can see, the
period is greater than 2pi.
And the solutions are
very far from sinusoids.
So that's the pred
prey app that's
available with the programs
in from the mathworks website
under NCM for Numerical
Computing with MATLAB.
Whoops, I stand corrected.
If you Google Moler predprey,
it tries to talk me out of it,
but then it shows it's in
my second book, Experiments
with MATLAB.
There are two books.
Numerical Computing with MATLAB
and Experiments with MATLAB.
And pred prey is in the second
one, Experiments with MATLAB.
You can go to
website and you can
download all of the
programs from EXM
or you can go down here
and here's pred prey.
So it's in Experiments with
MATLAB on the MathWorks
website.
Just Google Moler predator
prey and you'll find it.